so this is the e 380 and you would think
it would be an information technology
related thing and it actually is even
though it gets there by a kind of weird
grip so again as I was explaining when
we beforehand this actually started when
I was asked to be a skeptical discussant
for EE 380 in 2001 for Stephen Schneider
talking about climate and uncertainty
and I ended up getting involved in this
stuff and what I bended up doing is
studying groups studying the mechanisms
by which people create fog around
reality and sort of money comes in and
fog comes out it turns out that the
Steve Schneider yeah okay so Steve
Slater was a great Stanford climate
scientists and communicator who sadly
was deceased in 2010 and it would big
loss to the world but that's what got me
involved because you might ask why is it
computer scientists in this anyway it
turns out that big tobacco and big
fossil are very good gears in the wheels
of the machineries that create this
information they're also very good at
using the latest technologies they pick
them up really fast and and I'll give
some examples of that ok so what I'm
going to do is sort of introduce myself
I'll talk a little bit about climate
change science not much because it's
pretty clear
mostly I talk about the anti science
machineries of doubt doubt is often
almost better than disinformation it's
easier to create alright so an awful lot
of things are there not to convince
somebody the truth of something else to
just make them doubt the fairly clear
realities so some of this gets pretty
deep into politics there's a lot of room
in real politics for differences of
opinion but often politics is used to
actually you know be being complete
denial about clear
there's enough unclear things that one
can have decent arguments with people
different views but there are some
things where you know basic physics is
something you don't really argue about
so the tobacco folks have been doing
anti science for a long time
environmental anti science has picked
that up and certainly it's got a tight
relationship with politics I'll give
some examples of things you might be a
surprise to find that Joe Camel anybody
remember Joe Camel okay innocent
innocent okay you know not really
created to get teenagers okay by the way
mercury you and your fish is fine
there's no such thing as global warming
okay all right I'll talk a little bit
about the Minnesota social cost of
carbon case that's actually related here
to Stanford given the strong efforts in
the energy modeling forum anyway there's
a big in tangling with politics one of
the sad things is that that politics has
been overloaded to get people to
disbelieve science that twenty or thirty
years ago there was not such a split but
you find a lot of split now we'll talk a
little bit a in the middle of things but
also at the end of the applications in
the Internet age we'll talk a little bit
in throwing rocks in the gears and we'll
go from there
so which has a book signing event in
Berkeley last evening yes so ok all
right ok so here's here's a little
background I grew up on a small farm in
western Pennsylvania which is a funny
place because it's at the corner of
being farmland from Ohio being steel
from Pittsburgh being coal from
Appalachia and of course this is the
home of the Marcellus Shale and oil was
discovered you know not too far north of
there ok so it's a funny kind of place I
went to Penn State got recruited to go
to Bell Labs spent 10 years there the
license plate is my license plate still
have that came out here when the Bell
System was breaking up did
various things at various companies at
least some of which I team up old-timers
here you've probably heard of and then I
had a heart attack in 95 and eventually
my cardiologist said stop being stupid
and do something else
than being the chief scientist at
Silicon Graphics so I finally did and I
sort of did a typical semi-retired thing
that senior techies do here you know I'm
a trustee at the Museum I you know I'm
an advisory boards for startups we ski
and I can do stuff but then I got pulled
into this whole climate stuff starting
in 2001 first and trying to understand
the science and then being very puzzled
about why the obvious science wasn't
being acted on and I ended up getting
deeper and deeper into the study of the
disinformation industry and what I end
up doing these days is I do sort of
investigative journalism and publish
things reports on that stuff here are
some books you might just take a look at
these these are background I'll note
that this this presentation some of it
will be smaller letters and you can
possibly read this is you know I provide
the PDF it's more of a back up thing you
can go search for things these are all
good books a whole lot of them are by
friends of mine I know almost everybody
here and they come at the disinformation
problem from different directions but
they're well worth reading
for instance Robert Proctor is a
professor here of history he's probably
the leading historian about the tobacco
industry and that's a really thick book
I thought I knew this turf pretty well
he had so much more just quite amazing
let's see that certainly I don't how
many people will be the read or seen the
movie merchants of doubt' anybody that's
a good one to see okay right
the movie has some different stuff in it
that's not in the book and it's if
you're not in around this turf its it's
a real eye-opener I may be biased
because
know what's in the book as I've spent a
lot of time helping Matt I actually got
involved with that because I was I was
trying to track the attacks on one of
the authors Naomi arrests keys of
looking at how information flowed around
the internet because there was dis
information rapidly flowing around and
you if you were watching it while it was
going on you could see which blogs and
websites were watching each other
because you could see bad memes flowing
around okay and being an old information
guy I thought that was kind of
interesting to see okay so anyway those
are some good sources to read and
they're kind of depressing but they're
worth reading okay these are just lists
of some things that I've done there's
like thousands of pages this is just an
example you know the earth is getting
warmer we're doing it it's really raw
basic physics it's been around for over
a hundred years and you know we are
rapidly heading for a climate on earth
that we haven't seen for millions of
years okay right and you know I guess in
some places that'll be better it's kind
of too bad for Miami
it won't help us here in the Bay Area
either but you know the physics is
pretty solid the evidence is very
consistent with the physics so it's
going on so this is kind of thing you'd
think this would be hard to create doubt
about but you find a large number of
people don't believe it in fact it turns
out that an awful lot of what goes
around in terms of doubt creation gets
used again and again so this is a great
website by skeptical science and I'm one
of the team on this thing and what they
do is collect arguments that keep
appearing again and again and give them
numbers this is sort of like the old
joke about jokes that you know every
joke has a number okay so now you can
just say 20 and everybody will laugh
okay well that's like this okay right
there's there's a you know I I care
where the top five and the oldest ones
and what what's in this web
is a quick description a little longer
description and links to webpages that
go through sometimes of different layers
of detail alright what this is about
right the thing is these things get used
again and again and again they appear
well set they've been in the Wall Street
Journal op-ed z' for a long time and
sadly right now they're actually
appearing in the New York Times up it's
fellow named Bret Stevens right and it's
just you know the same wrong stuff gets
repeated again and again okay now you
can sort of categorize things a science
you know I mean a lot of people here are
science folks right I have an analogy of
the Great Wall which it says you know
science is like a wall it gets built up
over time you may be able to kick away a
stone or two and some of the things are
loose but you know after something's
been there and cemented in place for
hundreds of years it's kind of pretty
solid it doesn't just all fall down
because you find something a little
wrong then there's pseudoscience which
in which somebody has an idea that they
really really want to convince
scientists is true right and you know a
serious skeptics look at this stuff and
it turns out not to be any evidence but
it still comes back ESP astrology cycles
everywhere there's a guy who thinks the
Sun is made of iron
he also doesn't believe in climate
change like there's a whole bunch of
folks that that do what you call climb
astrology where they look at cycles of
the planets and everything and they
determine that global warming is all
caused by where Jupiter and Saturn
happen to be okay all right all right so
this of course in the medical business
is useful for cures you know I mean you
can improve all kinds of things if you
want to read some examples of this take
a look for the Journal of scientific
exploration okay it's got many good
things on ESP reincarnation astrology so
my favorite is the one that studied 500
parisian puppies and found that their
personalities matched their astrological
signs
okay right good well with astrological
sign oh that's okay well determines
blending building them into the lead
your big or small yes okay my life could
be all right yeah there are strange
thanks Amy this is my way is was quoted
as a crucial source by various folks
attacking the climate hockey-stick
how many people know the hockey stick
okay all right I'm you do right okay
well you know the the Journal of
scientific exploration was quoted in
that okay then there's science noise I
don't know of a real formal title for
this but you know this is the classic
problem that you start with science it
goes through the media and and and then
with no ill will whatsoever gets mangled
right not all scientists are great
communicators one of the things I really
admired about Steve Schneider that I
mentioned is he could communicate to
audiences of greatly varying expertise
which is really hard right now
admittedly one of his relatives told me
well what would you expect when he came
out of the womb he was talking to
everybody who would listen Oh God
so you know not everybody has that
advantage now anti science is different
from any of these it sometimes uses
pseudoscience they will latch on to
anything that sounds like it goes
against the the mainstream views but
it's more intended to obscure science
because there's some policy that's not
wished right nobody bothers with things
like you know a a cosmology that don't
affect you know what what policies one
has so it turns out that and I've done a
lot of time looking at this most of
these anti science means like those
arguments I showed are created by a
fairly small handful of professionals
who do this but then the whole issue is
how do you propagate that through the
blogosphere through the internet and so
forth right most of the people repeating
them did not create them in the first
place
all right but it's a very well done well
done effort at the dissemination so
here's the the overall structure which
is you you would like real science to
feed into reviews and you get assessment
reports and that should go into
government in publics and you know if
there's something relevant you go to the
political process and outcomes policies
you know based on the best science that
you've got but if you don't like how
that will end up that what you try to do
is create as much fog as you can hear
you say things like I will forget this
we need more research
well the interesting is more research in
definitely means you never ever do
anything right that's always that's
always a good one because you could say
well we really need more research
now how many science papers and with
more research is needed
yes oh yes okay so it's pretty yeah one
more funding I know okay too many too
many right here here yes how to select
99 I was sort of curious let's see um
yeah because for instance of the IPCC
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change was actually started under George
HW Bush okay right and if you backtrack
about then it there was not a real
strong visible split okay right now it
may have gotten fired up around 1988
when James Hansen talked about a climate
in Congress but but I mean you know this
is this is approximate okay so I'm
saying is it was a far less evident
split than it is today are you looking
computer engineering major in 1970
because are you bet on okay okay all
right so I would serve I'll be really
clear right I mean there's been a clear
split and
plenty of examples where where the where
whether or not climate scientist is true
has gotten tightly tied to a political
beliefs right and and I just want to be
clear you know there are plenty of
Republicans who were actually decent
defenders of science okay right
sure would bullet was a Republican from
New York in Congress terrific every
scientist I know thinks thinks the world
of him up going right yeah you know Bob
Inglis lost his job in South Carolina
because he actually went to Antarctica
and learned about climate if you thought
about the merchants of doubt' really
moving section of him trying to convince
people like so and George Shultz you
know it's quite amazing right but by now
it's really gotten heavily tied to
politics right and I'll play of Studies
on that
okay now the modern stuff is let me tell
you the cigarette guys are the best
marketeers on the planet right and they
got a in 1954 they were seeing that the
science was getting really against them
all right and they put together
materials a hill and opens big PR firm
and these were the tactics to be used
when you know that the science is
against you you know the evidence is
inconclusive well it's something else
right uhit's all statistics Beauvoir
okay and more research is necessary and
by the way all of this stuff is coming
back for electronic cigarettes all right
which and I'll go into that some all
right but you can see a repeat of all
the same stuff it's interesting now
what's interesting too is that often the
people being used to push the ideas are
some of the same people certainly some
of the same organizations there's quite
a few think tanks out there that if you
look at what they actually do they're
more like PR lobbying agencies alright
and they get a lot of money from both
fossil and tobacco folks
these things are by the way mostly 501c3
non profits not supposed to do certain
things nevertheless they do a lot of
things and I will note this because a
very good climate scientist named David
Kitley maybe I know that name okay he
was he was like the chief oceanographer
in the Navy he's after years
Admiral titli retired he said Penn State
these days and I know him and he
reminded me that I mean he said he's
affiliated with the Hoover Institution
here is that not all of the think tanks
you know do all this PR lobbying stuff
and actually Hoover I might look pretty
hard I haven't seen much from them of
this all right they're course they
proceeded the huge wave of coke based
think tanks that came from the 80s and
90s so uh you know it's just really
weird though to you know here are these
conservative libertarian think tanks and
it appears that a value is to be able to
help the tobacco industry addicts ten
agers all right I think you know show
you some examples that seems you're
weird now of course there are some
earlier things like lead you know the
lead guys you know we're pretty good at
this too I think what the tobacco folks
bought brought to the party was terrific
marketing lead guys were not really good
marketeers right tobacco folks are
incredibly good they're actually really
good Big Data folks to by the way right
you'd be amazed the details that they
keep tracking like literally how much
space is in every gas station I mean
that is they're really good okay now
here you can't possibly read this just
look at the red okay what I did is take
a page from Bob Proctor's book where he
looked at the tobacco playbook on the
left and with blood permission I just
took that and edited in to put the read
to be what's the modern equivalent for
the fossil guys so the main thing is G
it's all the same playbook right so
you know you can go look at the
references if you care to see what what
the details are but the thing is it
wasn't a hard edit okay you know I took
the page energy in and then copied it
and edit it in you know 20 minutes so it
wasn't hard okay now after the think
tanks think tanks have been taking money
from the tobacco guys for a long time a
real interesting thing well some of the
data runs out around 2001 2002 but we
noticed something that think tanks
around the first half of 2013 that for
years have been defending the tobacco
companies all of a sudden all started to
say well smoking is bad and that's why
cigarettes can help people okay now
right by some coincidence that was right
when the major tobacco companies who
fund these guys all decided they needed
to have a cigarettes what a funny
coincidence okay all right and it was
very a very nice edge sharp change of
what they were saying really somebody
told them the message you got a you know
you've got to get on board with what
we're actually going to do so anyway
e-cigarettes are really fun there's a
great website here at Stanford called
Sweta
all right which has a whole lot of the
marketing materials from cigarettes and
e-cigarettes of comparisons of where
they they reuse the old marketing themes
for e-cigarettes and great retread
materials there's great stuff like
there's hundreds of flavors of this
stuff bubble gum cotton candy gummy
bears probably my favorite by the way
all of these are really designed to help
adults quit smoking okay got that 15
right okay they're not they're not to
capture teenagers not at all not not no
chance okay right actually of course
that's what they're for teenage smoking
rates have been slowly when going down
and then in the last couple years the
e-cigarette use is gone
pretty fast now later for earlier for a
little older one sex cells poking right
and there's some amazing internet
commercials that's about all I can say I
probably couldn't show them here okay
all right but you know they they work on
that this one here says after a steamy
hotel scene says save humanity start
vaping the smoke comes the vapor comes
out and forms these things it's good
good graphics okay now some of these are
sold as being high-tech Google see
cigarette microcontroller right a bunch
of these things have a very small cheap
micros in and now use that as a
marketing thing that's to control the no
it's like Google I just mean Google
search this it's our Google is not
making easy okay anyway they are great
marketeers but nobody trusts them so you
always want independent looking third
parties alright and that's what they use
the sort of pseudo academic think tanks
for alright and and they there's been a
regular progression away from in obvious
industry groups towards independent
things that people might actually
believe they also come out for
testimonies you know if if if a
legislature is considering doing
something like raising cigarette taxes
or the raising age to 21 these folks
will marshal experts there's a whole
bunch of folks who do this interestingly
a whole lot of these folks they're
they've been in the cigarettes for a
long time and now they're in climate
stuff as well right now when the
ancients linguist was discovered by some
friends of mine at UCSF that the tea
party was really put together by the
Koch brothers one of their think tanks
and a lot of help from Big Tobacco in
fact the tea party motif came from a PR
firm that Philip Morris in right and
then the cokes hired tobacco marketeers
that's when I discovered the
because I recognized a name of a PR firm
that I heard up at UCSF and looked that
guy up and the tobacco archives up there
and there he was he's a long time
tobacco helper and so he and then he
moved over to be to run communications
for Koch Industries flies Dennis and I
armed with John and other speakers so
that is live online yeah so don't know
how ok so here's where the future goes
okay these guys are good i cost
something they've invested billions of
dollars in and there's a patent from a
couple years ago which basically shows
this with the idea that see there's some
kind of smoking device here and it's got
a USB cable over to the PC and it can do
things like download updates and upload
data okay now these things control the
puff rate and how much stuff goes in
there but no Bluetooth yeah I'm sorry
okay right they may do that later I
don't know you know okay okay now that's
not exactly how they worked out but if
you look around for IKOS that's what
these things are called this is what
really came out this is the thing you
puff on this is the controller for it
and then you have to put it back in this
bigger device to recharge it okay but
it's got a USB cable that goes to
something it could go just to a wall
socket the recharge or could go to a PC
okay right well they want that data they
want that date a lot they want part yes
well well yeah but yeah you know it
works okay right um and we I don't know
yet what they actually do but there's no
doubt about it there's plenty of
capability there to gather data about
each person's habits who use this
uploaded analyze it sends up back to
control they say make suggestions in the
patent that they can do things like help
people lower their usage okay right and
and but you know like like sort of
control the number of puffs you can have
in a month and stuff like
now how many people here believe that
these will be used to help people stop
smoking okay nobody what a funny thing
okay anyway a few Google I cos this is
it's not officially here in the US yet
but it's in a bunch of other countries
they're gearing up to have it of course
there's a whole raft of patents around
this they'd much rather have a product
that people use that's really hard to
duplicate okay now let's look at how the
whole structure works and this is an
overview and then I'm going to go
through the pieces at the top what one
finds are corporations and family
foundations then there's there's a big
cloud here well money goes through
clouds in funny ways sometimes you can
find it sometimes you can't there's a
bunch of cases where I can find about
30% of the money that comes to these
think tanks but not much more okay the
things that are 501 C freeze have to
file reports every year I've got like a
laptop full of these things alright and
you kind of to ferret out what they're
doing and it isn't easy but anyway money
comes in here it goes also to lobbyists
and other folks money flows down and
money is black red or ideas and memes
that get propagated and then you know
you come out to the bottom of the public
so let me do the pieces so at the top
again here's the money comes from
it goes through PR agencies lobbyists
course a lot goes directly to
politicians it goes to think tanks which
tend to have a more permanent existence
like Competitive Enterprise Institute or
Kate or whatever you have front groups
that tend to come and go alright they
get put together and you have to figure
out who actually runs them alright again
a lot of these come from the wave of
think tanks that the cokes funded a
hoover a preceded these and is a bit
different i put that in again they
typically reminds me that that's fair
okay right there's some others around
that are specific to climate this is the
one in the UK
this is a place out in Arizona the
center for the study of carbon dioxide
and global change which you never met a
co2 molecule that didn't like a whole
lot okay all right and here's more right
now
tobacco sometimes it its own front
groups but these days they generally use
their own think tanks for cover they
used to have smokers rights groups and
those really didn't work right what
worked with the tea party okay
now this piece is where the ideas come
from and the idea is the more credible
sounding somebody can be the happier
they are so ideally you get a climate
scientist or a medical researcher to
help you okay right
but those are hard right if you look at
congressional testimony and another sort
of climate dismissive things there's a
pretty small number of people who
actually ever had serious credentials at
climb however even a PhD sounds good
right and so you will find all kinds of
papers around that are complete nonsense
but having a PhD you know means credible
and then you get somebody at least
science technical like I'm an engineer
so you know it's good enough right and
otherwise you just get whoever you can
that will communicate over here are real
hacks who just do whatever they do for
the money okay
there's some well-known ones in that
category okay
so the idea here is this is where all
those means come from where I killed you
the top five but there's like hundreds
of them okay and there's a constant flow
with these things so you know you get
some in the UK this is the one who got
me started chasing this this Christopher
Moncton anybody ever hear this guy yes
okay well he's an interesting guy
he's a British lord who's pretty crazy
that's all I could say okay now for the
US there's a great series of things
called the six Americas research thing
where they survey the US and they
clustered people into sort of six groups
and they ask different questions and see
who
believes what the climate denialism
stuff focuses on causing confusion for
these groups and hoping that some go
into what you call dismissive meaning we
absolutely reject it there's a hard core
folks who simply act just just simply do
not believe this believe that there is
any human influence on climate change
down here are the folks who actually
think that it's real and you have to do
something but the arguments are over the
folks in the middle just like the
arguments in politics tend to be over
the uncommitted folks in the middle now
this used to be just sort of the general
print media but by now the blogosphere
and all the online things are serious
factors that's really only happened over
the last yeah 10 15 years
alright and where there used to be more
fact-checking
you know it's Wild West over there right
and you can find stuff that you would
agree with you no matter what it is and
it's up I would say it's one of the
biggest challenges is that human society
hasn't yet adapted to figuring out how
you easily know whether something is
reliable or not all right
and unfortunately the the folks doing
this stuff even got there earlier than
folks who are just trying to do their
science ok so anyway there there's the
whole overall structure one of the
crucial things here is to get support
here that filters back up to the
politicians what you want are angry
people writing to letters to editor and
to their local representatives saying
this climate change stuff is a hoax it
felt terrible Richard Lyndon says so so
they are okay right and quietly sort of
supporting the politicians that also may
be getting money from from up there or
at least you know convincing the people
who waver about this here was an example
of the the political split Larry
Hamilton's
a sociologist actually does a lot of
Arctic sociology from the University of
New Hampshire and they did a really nice
thing is that they split things four
ways although the colors sort of aren't
your normal thing it's sort of it's
democratic independent Republican except
for Tea Party and Tea Party now one of
the interesting things here is that when
they ask actual questions about the
science like our glaciers decreasing
looking right the Tea Party knows the
least but they are the ones who are sure
they know the most now reason I think
that this is pretty important is there
is a if you look at the orange and the
green there's actually you know fairly
substantial difference here if you only
call everything Republicans I think it
it masks the fact that there's two
pretty different populations in there
all right but again I think this is
something that's that a lot of that has
been created over the last you know 25
years or so because I don't think it was
a tea party didn't exist before
okay now where are these think tanks all
these are all research institutes they
just happen to have to be within a
couple blocks of Congress okay you know
just where you need research institutes
to be okay you know anyway K Street K
streets over here and a whole lot of
them are right here there's a few
elsewhere there's a couple under
California there's one in Chicago but a
whole lot of them are in Washington DC
okay now this is another one don't worry
about the detail I went through and
looked at the extent that I could in
2010 about who was here was across the
top where the think tanks going down was
known funding so this was tobacco
funding this was different organizations
they were and this was Exxon two
different views of this these were key
big Family Foundation's this was Richard
Mellon Scaife everybody here know that
name okay if you okay
I'm Pittsburgh guy I've heard of him
or he's really nice guy when when his
wife left him he put a sign on his front
lawn that say have lost wife and dog a
reward for dog hmm nice guy but he's
funded a lot of these things the Koch
guys of course have funded a lot and
this is a huge matrix that showed where
the money came from and where it went
all right so it turns out there's a you
know there's about the real real paper
has about a hundred think tanks and
maybe a hundred different foundations
here the only reason you can find that
is because since they used their
foundations they have to report where
the money goes
now they fix that later they in created
a mechanism by which they could make it
anonymous more or less okay now this is
one for the tobacco side of this I was
studying the Heartland Institute anybody
hear that oh yeah great guys okay I
found that there was a tobacco executive
named Roy Mardan who was on their board
for 12 years okay and I said oh you know
I'm trying to find money flows okay so I
said I wonder if he's in the tobacco
archives up at UCSF he was not only that
he was the guy in Philip Morris who gave
out money every year to the think tanks
and he had a spreadsheet every year I
said thank you thank you you just save
me so much time okay all right and most
of that was from you know most of this
is from that that thing you be just
surprised there's just you know money
and lovely comments about who was doing
a good job okay and begging letters like
we have really done good stuff for you
this year give us some more money we're
going right tobacco archives up at UCSF
are a great source I wish we had the
equivalent for environmental sciences
but we don't okay all right there's
ninety million pages of internal tobacco
company documentation yes and a lot of
its sort of Peters out around two
thousand one inch or so but still stuff
keeps coming in because get
documents is the number one thing that
everybody says all right so you know
it's a it's always worth doing that
anyway it's great data very clear in bed
with the tobacco industry the whole time
and again the question was are they
still doing it in the 2013 thing with
ecig arete pretty well proved it because
all in LOX Inc they all decided that
each cigarette swear good thing to help
you stop much smoking which suddenly had
become bad after all these years
okay this is what they do for the money
I found this document in there and it's
great so they're going to do press
releases they're going to do op eds and
they're going to do policy briefs and
letters to the editor the one I love the
best is weathers letters to congressmen
let's see-oh down towards the bottom we
find this one I love this access to GW
Bush okay when he was a Texas government
okay cuz of hey these are nonprofits
right nonprofits they get a tax break
for this stuff okay good
anyway this was from a document that was
in the in the tobacco archives your main
problem with the archives if he's got a
very nice search engine or publicly
available but you have to craft your
queries well to focus in on things if
you put in Exxon you get 20,000 hits
interesting all right now here we go
here's hardline Institute so if you
privatize profits and socialize the
damages Heartland can help you alright
so again it's a tax-exempt public
charity it was infamous for this big
billboard okay a few years back right
this one actually cost them a million or
two bucks of industrial funding right it
only lasted a day or two but you know
they put it up outside Chicago
let's see there's a letter from from the
president Joe best saying Joe Camel was
innocent and it was a article he did and
then he wrote to Philip Morris saying
hey see the good article we did for
old you should give us more money okay
it's all sitting there in the thing and
you know there's a lot I wrote a long
report that has all this good stuff
right so you know here's the kind of
advertisement if you remember Joe Camel
you know now who could this possibly be
aimed at okay Abby yeah what could I say
why this mat but we got your computer
geeks Yeah right okay right well okay so
why is this well uh the crucial thing is
something actually most adults don't
know are even well educated folks is
that physiologically it's almost
impossible to get addicted to nicotine
except during adolescent brain
development okay right
the statistics are there the physiology
is more complicated it has to do with
the while certain parts of the brain are
plastic during adolescence okay right
you can basically rewire the brain okay
right you create more nicotine ik
receptors and then that's what creates
the addiction but the statistics are
really clear here's ages this is when
people started okay hey it's pretty well
over by about 19 or 20 all right I'm
consistent 11 for boys yes yeah there's
a there's a this document for the
National Academies Institute of Medicine
I includes work from Bonnie Halpern fell
sure who's a professor here right and
they go through in great detail this was
this was behind the age 21 hmm stuff
right and the idea there was you know 18
year olds are often still in high school
they buy the cigarettes give them to
their friends and by 21 they kind of
moved on anyway it just rocks all with
science it's really really hard to get a
addicted to nicotine after adolescent
brain development but they say the
tobacco industry has known this for a
long time at three years before Joe
Camel came out was the importance of
younger adults and it's all spelled out
in there
the younger adults by the way means 1218
I don't say that but that's what they
mean okay so this is the kind of stuff
that Heartland would run here we go they
had a smokers lamps in 2006 that was a
section of their their website here was
the thing in 2008 here's the guy smoking
about two feet away from a young girl
okay right hey no problem with
secondhand smoke what was all the site
says something else but that's okay
right they're still getting money at
least as of 2012 because of the fish
that got some of their documents they
are still getting money and actually
more than they were years ago oh by the
way a coal is just fine and fish in the
environment they get a lot of coal money
too okay well we'll skip this this is
what Joe bass says all the time no
problem no problem we're good guys okay
alright now this is another one you
won't be able to read the details but it
shows the kind of stuff we do which is
here our funders at the top then the
funds go to lots of think tanks the
think tank guys all right for each other
quote each other you know to show who's
with it these guys produce all kinds of
reports and things legislators guide
yeah they send this thing called the
Environment and climate news to all of
the state and local legislators I check
that they even sent them to the local
Democrats and what they do and they say
well we throw them out all right but
there's a constant flow of stuff where
they're trying to feed stuff to
legislatures all over the place if
they're all entangled with various folks
I say Michael Crichton state of fear man
he was their favorite for years and
years and years they would run big ads
it said Michael Crichton was right
you know the Crichton's book basically
says you know climb
scientists are baddies directed and they
have a big cabal and hoax and everything
and in Crichton fashion it was you know
a good thriller okay but we also have a
pretty good idea of who he was talking
to to get to climate stuff out anyway
these things are all inner tangled like
this right it's sort of like untangling
some of the current political funding is
that you find funny connections here
near that they really don't want you to
to know about okay well here's another
one I wanna say this I have friends at
George Mason University
but some parts of it might as well be
Koch brothers subsidiaries - but they
also have done good stuff for the
tobacco folks over years right there was
this wonderful thing here it was an
economics Network in the 80s which
basically was to find local university
folks across all the states to testify
at a legislative meeting so cool right
and so you can find the funding flows
and who did what and how well X Y Z is
looks good on paper but he's not very
good in front of legislators we need
somebody else great stuff anyway some of
the crucial coke think tanks are right
there one of them the Institute for
Humane studies is actually chaired by
Charles Koch all right yeah being good
it's as University it's probably the key
school for this kind of stuff and law
and economics places but most of the
places in Normal University okay ed may
block is a terrific researcher on
climate communication he's one of the
ones who did that Yale six Americas
thing okay great great guy he comes out
to American Geophysical Union meetings
and there's other folks there that are
fine it's just there's a couple places
you nervous raises a question you
ferment example one yeah so you had this
guy Bob Carter I see you have him
Pacific Australia New Zealand you have
an Ag a question mark
and my question is my impression is that
in Europe they're actually pushing
smoking out of the various non-english
speaking countries and because of their
their health systems are trying to place
greater emphasis on China evening can
you are you going to comment on that
because of the fact that these are
largely English language yeah okay well
is that Indian right there front okay
India the reason for the India thing is
okay so so right you see the complexity
of this chart this is a tiny fraction of
the connections and stuff that there is
a parrot what happens is the
english-speaking gang is very tightly
coupled together the climate denial and
cigarette denial folks in Europe are
pretty tightly coupled but the language
gets in the road so I'm okay I've run
across a couple things from India not
much right for the smoking side okay Bob
Carter was a climate guy who's now dead
hooking right there's a fairly strong
climate and cigarette gang in Australia
they've been losing big Australia did
this thing called plane packs alright I
think if you know it's a it's a
beautiful marketing it's terrible
misnomer all of the cigarette packages
have to look the same with the same
colors and fonts and sizes getting right
and the front of it has to have one of n
really ugly pictures okay right I mean
really bad stuff okay right and the
cigarette companies fought this like
crazy and I'll actually address this a
little bit later but Australia kept
winning these battles and other
countries have been picking it up okay
indeed the the tobacco companies care
about two things one is making sure that
they can addicted Xin the window because
if they don't get them then their net
will never be customers the second thing
is keeping government as far away from
health care as they can hmm
all right that's why they get involved
in building the Tea Party okay all right
the idea is you don't you you want to
have people able to say well somebody
smoked then they died but it's not me
and I don't have to pay for it if if you
think your taxes are going towards
health care all of a sudden you care
more okay all right so those are the two
things that they hate a nurse if you
read the poison tea book you can read
about the the the attacks that they did
on various health I mean those are the
two things they care about
okay all right so China is definitely a
problem here's a smoking problem okay a
60% of Chinese men smoke 50% of the
doctors right and the BigDog
of cigarette companies there is China
tobacco which is owned by the state yeah
which could be slightly hard to regulate
okay all right okay so so the answer is
yeah there's connections that I have
some names that I have a big
spreadsheets got a thousand names that
okay right and in different countries
and things but but but the focus here is
more right here is more on the
english-speaking ones just because it
can't do everything I mean if you did
the whole chart for this it'd be this
whole room okay now this is another one
okay and believe me these folks are
right in there there's three groups
American Association physicians and
surgeons doctors for disaster
preparedness and the Oregon Institute of
science and medicine okay anybody ever
hear of these entities yeah oh you have
that's my wife of course you Berger okay
talk about all of that anyway
okay this is an interconnected gang of
folks right okay the aaps absolutely
believes government should have nothing
to do with healthcare period it's just
purely doctor/patient okay nothing right
and by the way they don't really like
insurance companies either and they
certainly don't like medical review
boards thanks got none of this doctors
for disaster preparedness started
decades ago basically to help people
prepare for nuclear war right but at
least half
of the half of the sessions that they do
they have a like a two-day conference
every year one or two days a half of the
sessions are explaining why there is no
problem with environment there's no such
thing as global warming blah blah blah
okay that's what the speakers are that
they get they get whoever they can get
to do this
why exactly 150 doctors need to hear
that there's no such thing as global
warming I don't know but that's who
comes up for this the organ Institute of
science and medicine is a really jolly
place it's in cave junction Oregon looks
like a big barn the to fact it has a
list of faculty although it's mostly art
Robinson and his sons and the two
faculty members listed at the beginning
are both dead both been dead for 10 plus
years okay but they're still there
listed you know and art I this whole
bunch was involved in a thing called the
Oregon petition
anybody know about that this was 30,000
people have signed a petition to say
there's no such thing as global warming
okay right a lot of them were full but
it was if they're presented as being
scientists but they're not art also runs
for Congress every election to the last
couple funded by a fellow named Robert
Mercer anybody know that name Robert
Mercer okay all right well in fact
Mercer apparently has attended meetings
of DDP look good right so we've got some
interesting folks here these are the two
who run it and I've looked at hours of
videos by these folks and well they're
interesting let us say okay all right
Robert Mercer is embroiled Ron Paul Tom
Price tonight Andrew Schlafly anybody
know that name no names loffley yeah
yeah okay go look at conserva pedia
sometime okay yes oh great yes okay yeah
I recommend it okay uh it's connection
with reality is minimal okay anyway
these folks are all in this sort of
thing there's multiple multiple 501c
freeze they publish stuff like here's
the Journal of this thing the aaps
publishes
and stuff well that's kind of weird okay
right anyway
it's like there's this whole gang of
folks this is about as far out as you
can get they say good things about
cigarettes they don't like vaccinations
okay they don't like climate science
okay and you know Tom prices in there
he's one of their favorites right by the
way the FDA was about to put
restrictions on e-cigarettes and those
were just delayed okay and of course
that reports to him okay this is a great
report I'll just mention it briefly and
look this did a much more serious later
analysis of money flows the crucial
thing that went on here was actually
something I actually discovered in 2012
is this thing called the donors trust or
donors capital fund basically this is a
donor advised fund you give money to it
you still control where it goes but only
one person writes the check so now you
can't tell who gave what money to him
okay and this was basically set up by
cokes and friends to anonymize where the
money was going because Charles Koch has
hated the fact that his family
foundations of gifts were ever had to be
recorded okay and what you see here is
these were funds going directly from the
found their foundations this was money
coming out through donors trust and
basically over the years the money
shifted from direct up through donors
trust beautiful design okay this is
another one sort of looking at the
future the social cost of carbon now
this is a lot of work John Wyatt does a
lot of this at the energy modeling forum
right where you know figuring out how
much it really costs to admit carbon
dioxide is really hard work there's lots
of models people try to thrash through
the things to get something and there
was a great great set of hearing
in Minnesota and Minnesota is pretty hip
all right
they had a law 20-plus years ago that
you had to account for a carbon okay
right and they set a fairly low price on
it at that point because the people to
know much right well a year ago they
were having a big discussion a big set
of hearings a Peabody Coal anybody know
them Peabody
okay big big gold company what you know
it collected some of the classic climate
deniers to come out and say white all
wasn't true and and yeah you know they
they analyzed the cases I mean hundreds
and hundreds of pages this is kind of
where the mainstream is up here you know
thirty forty kind of thing in fact a
bunch of the the oil companies for
internal pricings actually use that good
right these guys means to all want it to
be just a few dollars in one case they
wanted to be negative that is that you
should be that is that you should get
benefits you should get extra money from
the fact that you're emitting co2
because it's going to make everything
better for plants right I mean that's
the idea I'm a little farm boy okay I
may know the thing lie Biggs law okay
lie Biggs law is let's see that that the
growth of a plant is limited by whatever
is in least supply this is about
different fertilizers and so forth
apparent and it's sort of the simplest
thing is no amount of co2 is going to
make corn be good in the Sahara Desert
okay right but these guys don't believe
that okay there's a physicist at he was
at Princeton name will happen he was he
he took over the George Marshall
Institute which is the focus of
merchants of doubt' looking right and he
is like as I mean he's a he's a member
of the National Academy for atomic
physics but he's just like completely
wrong and totally ideological on the
climate stuff anyway if you ever want to
see the kinds of stuff that goes
to delay and create doubt this is a good
detailed example even thing was over
here Excel energy it's actually pretty
sensible cooking right - and they
actually you know they do las up with
wind right they they want to phase out
coal in a sort of disciplined fashion
right and they judge actually like the
other judge she was tough she shredded
these guys up guys in pink up just it
was it was a it was you know it glad in
my heart about the judicial system
great job by her okay so here's some of
the tactics you do endless petitions
Fred singer the Didem Oregon petition
with Robinson if you want to get a feel
for Robinson Google uh Rachel Maddow art
Robinson there's some absolutely amazing
video footage and she had them on right
but see there were attacks ben santer's
a great climate scientist at Lawrence
Livermore and they you know they went
after him in the Wall Street Journal in
the mid-90s at one point he heard a
noise at his door when he came down he
found an eviscerated rap sitting there
while somebody in the Hummer drove away
okay
that's not much very fun all right in a
late 2000s they did a strong effort to
subvert the climate statements of them
science societies American Physical
Society American Chemical Society the
Geological Society of America
IOP physics society and UK those are the
ones I know about that I had some hand
in helping stop okay but they went all
out to try to get a small group of
intense people in each society to push
things into against the climate science
they've often done things to try to
subvert peer review into pal review and
then blame scientists for doing that
right I did a big study on one of those
okay some of you heard of the hockey
stick curve which pretty straightforward
use of paleoclimate data and there's a
tactic that's come out of that where you
pick one scientist from a bunch of done
to work and you go after them pull out
and you blame them for everything they
did it first with Ben and that Mike man
got up a big bullseye painted on his
back as it turns out Mike's a friend of
mine okay right he stayed at our house
for goodness sakes it's made him way
more famous than you would have been
okay right you know being right and
being attacked all the time actually
makes you famous but you know they even
organized this thing called the Wegman
report anybody hear that okay all right
Wegmans report was basically a show
trial in the and Congress done by Joe
Barton of Texas right and they they
couldn't get they didn't want to get the
National Academy of Science to do a
study so they got a George Mason
University statistician and his
basically is grad students to do a
report and was completely bogus in fact
30 percent of it was plagiarized
they even plagiarized one of the authors
of the hockey stick okay right except
they did things because they didn't like
the conclusions I mean it was amazing
stuff regard now anyway it was just
completely bogus I literally went
through and annotated the whole thing up
during right
and later Wegmans sued me about it but
that's okay okay you lost okay
Climategate this may sound familiar
remember that Climategate in 2009 let me
think what the mechanism was steal a
bunch of email and then put it up
starting on a Russian server mmm so son
anybody hear anything like this okay all
right and okay now it looks like with
the French when they did this they
inserted bad documents as well okay
right yes mark yeah okay right with this
one I don't think they did that what
they did just put up all the emails but
then they carefully selected things that
if you knew the subject or nothing
okay I'm just in a normal science
scientists arguing okay right but you
could make them look like there was
something
they had going on right and you know it
people look at it there were review
committees and everything and there was
nothing okay but it caused a lot of flak
in the meantime and the same thing was
mainstream media quite nationally didn't
have the expertise to figure this out so
that's not familiar to okay right and
that's part of the way this works is
that if you go into what looks like
technical weird stuff you can put things
over in it you need we need the regular
media to be good on their skepticism and
sometimes they're not okay now there's
great use of the internet Marc Morano is
one of the hacks that I mentioned he
will often post some scientists email
address that's a signal to the folks who
read his blogs okay to go attack okay
and the next thing it happens is there's
this wave of hate mail and stuff that
comes okay all right I have I have least
a dozen friends who've been subjected to
this at one thing another no as far as I
know nothing ever actually happens but
they really hansel people okay okay
let's see cuz this is possible
deniability
he just had to put up the email address
he didn't tell them to do anything yeah
okay now fortunately yeah yeah
unfortunately scientists are learning
about this stuff early on it was a
terrible shock like for Ben it probably
contributed breaking up his marriage
okay right I know of people who are
really shocked and worried about this
stuff I've spent hours on phones with
people under attack you know saying okay
yeah you know yeah they're coming
through night now in a week or two
they'll be gone okay right nobody's
gotten hurt but you know let's work
through this and everything okay they're
just a pain anyway people who learned
about this I I'm an American Geophysical
Union member I go to the meetings yearly
meeting up here they've gotten a lot
better about understanding the tactics
of this stuff okay now these guys are
good about leading edge use of
Technology yeah I know I lost on during
so 1991 the greening of planet Earth and
there's a link to that
right here this was a VHS tape they put
out to the thousands of libraries in the
US the Western Fuels Association which
is Wyoming cold and did this here's a
link this is the end part where they
show that increased co2 will green the
earth
you notice the Sahara Desert is green
okay right right yeah okay climate check
all right okay okay nineteen
ninety-seven there's a website by this
guy here who lives and he was a not a
scientist lived in New Zealand he did
still waiting for green house and it
basically was a whole lot of those bad
memes originate from there although they
hate they fed stuff to him because it
was really a science but he would crank
this stuff out and for quite a while it
was sort of one of the most popular
websites because there wasn't much about
it
scientists did real science and
published papers and stuff like that
this guy was aimed at at other people
and he was a science advisor for the
Western Fuels Association funny
coincidence blogs really got going I'd
say around 2006 and there was a huge
outpouring of anti science climbing that
day science blogs there was the the
Climategate thing then and since then
lots of social media these guys are very
quick on their okay both both the both
tobacco and in climate and other things
too you know as it's been harder to have
ads on TV the tobacco guys are very good
about movie placements they pay a lot of
money to get things at the boobie of
course the Internet is good there's lots
of ads and commercials you can have on
there alright there's lots of websites
that are support groups for smokers
being hassled by by people Al and these
guys are good about moving to wherever
there is it's not well controlled that's
getting harder in the developed world to
do that but they're of course moving to
the developing countries the current
estimate is by who is probably a billion
people will die of smoking in this
century okay you know it 100 million
last century which puts them right up
there with
Stalin and Hitler well above okay okay
well this is advice I give to two
scientists you know there are things
like the climate science Legal Defense
Fund right everybody ought to watch
merchants of doubt' in right that's a
quick way to sort of get into this and
there are copies around on the web right
I always tell people if you get attacked
go quickly get advice from people who've
been through this before all right
that's a whole lot of younger climate
scientists say the guy who helped me the
most was Steve Schneider that I said
started me into this stuff Union
Concerned Scientists is pretty good
about this climate science Legal Defense
Fund is a entity that helps climate
scientists with the attacks and you know
if Marc Morano publishes your email hey
hate mail will come but it dies down
okay I'm going to skip these detailed
comparisons so they don't like exposure
much will happen
Princeton does not like me believe me it
is not like me right you sometimes can
do academic misconduct complaints I
basically managed to lose his his Wegman
and his accomplice eventually lost their
jobs as editors right they they filed
two million dollar lawsuits and you know
we wiped them out
basically right had there been complaint
but what actually didn't cost me
anything because a CSL DF paid for it
because I came they decided in this ago
it would have cost forty five thousand
right they decided in the middle of this
that that I qualified as a member of the
climate science community and they would
help me out okay
now if things had already been settled I
would have probably gone directly to
them to get legal help because they have
a bunch of pro bono lawyers but because
of the speed requirements just happens
it just happens I'm old buddies with
some of the best lawyers who know this
tax on climate science okay right which
I'm sure these folks had no idea I had
as contacts okay these folks are really
good okay and I knew they would blow
them away and they did so so but is the
kind of stuff that goes on there's a
whole bunch of lawsuits and foil
requests and stuff that are just
complete nonsense that they used to
harass climate scientists right
I mean foliage eneral II if we open
information it's generally a good thing
right but it can be misused in pretty
grim ways just completely chew up
people's time you know I have friends
out at Arizona that are going through
that right now okay
well you talked about scripts here
earlier gee I went to a meeting workshop
of for a couple days in scripts up on
the bluffs how many people been to
scripts watch it okay this is a real
real hardship you have to sit up there
look at the Pacific look at La Jolla
Beach compared you know work okay right
but yeah well you know okay anyway a
great group of this is the report that
came out right this lady here is a an
American heroine how caring right Sharon
Eubanks
she was the department justice lawyer
who broke the RICO suit against the
tobacco companies despite everything the
Bush administration could do to try to
make it go away okay right terrific lady
okay she was there she read a great book
about this which is one of the ones in
my my first list she's on the advisory
committee but the UCSF with made
terrific right but also showed how much
effort it took to make that happen
because the defenses against that were
were pretty fierce okay so it was
interesting though this last year gee
the coal companies all went bankrupt
generally mostly because of cheap gas
some renewables also made a whole bunch
of stupid investments EPA well we'll see
you know under the current government
with you know what could be done there
but I think an awful lot of that is this
stuff is the cheap gas and renewables
keep getting Cheaper by the way the coal
companies have all given payments to the
think tanks in to help do this stuff
right some of its visible some of it's
hard to find
I mentioned this thing with a social
cost of carbon again the judge just did
not buy their arguments like she whacked
them pretty good I will note very often
interesting legal actions start with the
state attorneys general all right and
and work their way up and that's
probably a good thing okay
so the tobacco guys built some anti
science machinery and tactics they paid
for it for a long time
environmentally and I think and have
inherited a bunch of this and it's often
the same people it is for sure a whole
lot of the same tactics let's see a
difference is the climate anti science
has much more distributed funding if you
say who's funding the tobacco anti
science well you start with Philip
Morris and Reynolds and then you work
your way down
beat that you know the other guys okay
with the climate science obviously the
fossil companies do it to some degree or
either but there's all these big family
foundations that do it more for ideology
or or there's a mix the cokes are both
money and on ideology alright there's
this odd connection you know tobacco to
do it you have to cut down trees see
sometimes take away farmland alright and
then you burn more wood to cure the
tobacco good right anyway Ron Pawnee is
said the the tobacco control folks have
been used to this stuff for decades dang
right they recognize tactics just like
that okay it's one reason I go up to
UCSF all the time
climate folks have now sort of gotten on
board and understand it a lot better
because it's pretty aliens in normal
science we hope it doesn't take as long
as tobacco control because warming is
kind of permanent again I you know while
there was some split twenty five years
ago it wasn't so partisan as it is now
okay because it's really partisan it's
too bad so I end up by thanking the
folks up at UCSF for the tobacco
archives
it's incredibly useful like I said why
just why do you think put an X on the
tobacco archives where does it get
20,000 hits so I don't know yet because
I haven't researched it it may be some
tighter coupling in other places but the
crucial thing is 60% of cigarettes sold
are through gas stations and convenience
stores okay it believe me take big data
these guys they know exactly where
everything is they know every gas
station okay they track them there's
memos flying around about you know well
we've lost a little shelf space to this
one gas station I mean they guys that
best marketeers drawer okay so I might
finish this me up I guess we have time
for a few questions
[Applause]
and the PDF that give you the PPS here
so people duck in all of this is
internet related of course the classical
print media has been letting go of their
science people yet I assume that that
includes all the tax centers yeah well I
mean you know there's a real sponge to
good journalists all right okay you know
I mean not the the age-old a financial
model is pretty bad we work all right
now some of them are doing better I
think wasn't been posting mostly the New
York Times are pretty decent there's
plenty of smaller groups getting funded
and growing up that aren't mainstream
media that are pretty good at this stuff
but they're not mainstream media yeah so
I don't have a magic answer that I come
to journalism books pretty often and
it's you know the inability to do fact
checking is a real problem of course
when it comes to science it's really a
problem I never take issue with that
I was in Europe times shares more about
thought thieves whatever you signs with
her okay well guys like Justin Gillis
are pretty good well you're gonna be a
bar top here in about 20 minutes
yes oh but honey come to Johnny Johnson
got cynical about it yes yes okay all
right oh hey but I think I mentioned
like the two best I know okay because
Wall Street Journal is really weird you
know some of the reporting is actually
pretty good but the obvious they just
are hopeless of myself I mean there's
not bad from this summer we're home and
Jenkins basically said nicotine is an
excellent drug only mildly addictive
well okay all right better than I'll get
pinched right nobody's doing any back to
checking on that so so so the the
problem is if it's a problem for those
guys you can imagine what it's like for
a local newspaper it's tough stuff I
wish I knew a magic answer but but you
know it's it's tough I don't know you
know New York Times particularly this
latest thing of hiring Bret Stevens was
pretty very weird I don't know I thought
they were trying hard to go more for
effectively yes is there any carryover
on the privacy front like the data
brokers any links there ah well what
that's all that's a whole different
thing okay right there's no doubt about
it this is my [ __ ] is a cigarette guys
and their data stuff right okay you know
pros guys collect data like crazy
they want to get more personalized data
there's again I can't tell from what's
out there on I cost yet unfilled Moore's
I cost all right there's no doubt about
it that the that the technology is quite
capable of gathering data about what
you're doing and monitoring it and
controlling it to optimize something and
don't think that something is to helping
you stop so so you know you put that in
an environment where there are so the
multiple examples you
of people having emails after databases
have everything and it is a serious
challenge yeah it's a serious challenge
you know the one good thing I guess is
that given given the press on this last
election is it's getting to be more more
visible for more people right I mean so
nobody could ever prove the Climategate
was a Russian thing not and you know it
is if you people were giving the Norfolk
was Norfolk in UK they were giving the
police a hard time so you didn't do
enough but buying who stole the emails
okay well they didn't find out about it
for a while and I had to say look
there's three cases one it was an inside
job which I hope really prints them but
if it was they would find it second was
it was an amateur who left tracks in
which case they would find it real quick
the third is it was a pro job in which
case they would never find it I said hey
I doubt that if it was later and it was
by pros the Palo Alto police couldn't
find it even helped by the NSA okay I've
been in the NSA in this area I'm like
it's like you know some of these things
like cozy bigger and then the gangs over
in Russia are really pretty good at this
if you're not watching why what's going
on is really pretty hard good so I least
that many people get a little bitter
about you know what they're doing
chocolate chip is do a particular
interpretation of the title I negate
with whoever did it was yeah I wish to
knock it had the data from you know Bose
the stuff was old it was to cause
trouble for the Copenhagen round if I
can proceed was way very well time there
was a freakanomics class we can resume
you asleep ability and interesting
discussions
climate stuff I haven't heard a shot
yeah although I had I've seen climate
stuff from for dynamics cuz it did not
impress me
so we'll say I think they're better
things I've heard suggested that a lot
of means I'm faced with those
questionnaires what comic book character
on a slide which Keane you're Keane -
like are actually really data mining
operation is again yes I I believe that
that is true
I mean yeah obviously one thing they
have a whole talk of that that's where
the stuff repair right but I didn't so I
have a facebook login but only so I can
login that can comment on some things I
have no friends on purpose right I put a
information in the record because it so
you know I have reservations about the
privacy people I don't think is nothing
alike yes for you know I want that's the
most quiz i sir just facebook yes you
can get over it right for job why are
the reservations I think that's whatever
it may suggest so just exactly because
that is both NATO mighty guess okay well
here's that okay so look I've been sued
for a couple million bucks I'm dying
right there are some people who really
don't like some of the stuff that I've
read okay and I'm not going to make
social networks obvious trust the
security there so so then on more
serious like I meet the requirement of
sides and politics is always in
programmatic I mean science is a pretty
bad record right and distorted speaking
right there whether to learn all kinds
of people and when Neptune was
discovered everybody was looking for
planet Vulcan right yes
sentimental and so sides not that great
right and if you look at what the
fascist did with the communist state
project signs in the Soviet Union and
Nazi Germany right so what makes is
different
well why do you think that this is right
science and success your ideology
whether you're taken off of them
confirmation bias Medora I'll be looking
for what you like a lot of people of
work for what they like protect login is
bad probably right I am ninety-nine
percent right and but so are many other
things right religion has been
particularly contrition like if you read
SF it's out there and it's protective
it's only support so I what's the point
so low good well the point is basic
physics say that where we are will be
underwater
you've got no debate so okay so Miami
will be gone all right so so the planet
is warming and that is just right that
it's red spot yet and and so let's say I
have a set of bookshelves this I I have
a whole lot of friends who are members
of the Academy of Sciences in climate
science I go to a GU meetings right I
read tons I below you know I have
heavily marked up IPCC stuff the science
is very sorry right
and the question is um we can just let
what goes you know we can let this we
can let things just proceed and the the
level of damage to the planet is really
pretty hard but if suppose the planet
the planet will still be here to good
right but the United States especially
is rich in part because there's a huge
amount of coastal infrastructure that's
going to be flooded out you know hair
that's okay
most of the reasons no no you have you
know for instance Russia is in pretty
good shape st. Petersburg is the one big
city when the coast it has the benefit
of post-glacial rebound where it's
actually going up a little bit
right is that significant I'm with Carol
okay some going out well it's certainly
significant on the scale of Ladner who's
like trying to get out of the pretty
much one try at what Chinese the other
one it gets you know the two countries
they have huge amounts of coastal
infrastructure us and giant right yeah
well it is pretty bad we just got you
know would have more from Syria like
home buyers cozily good part of them all
these greedy but yeah yeah but if you
look at the financial loss is not the
human wide losses as Chris Chris field
here maybe no Chris general so Chris
Lunz woods Institute but he was the
founding director for the Carnegie the
Department global ecology and he really
knows his stuff good night and when he
puts it is you know the monetary losses
will be in they developed countries the
human life losses will be in the poorer
countries which is what I'll have to
figure there's Bangladesh whatever they
get yeah but but you know we and then
China I mean again anybody here been to
Shanghai yeah okay well you know I've
been along the Bund there something
right that is a huge metropolitan area
with several rivers coming out you know
at that sexy level and then they build
dikes okay well I'm not sure but they're
you know you know the prom with Miami
and dykes
I know it's it's limestone is porous
limestone
okay you can't build sea walls of one
just comes on I like with the Dutch that
actually about colleen's after Katrina
when they keep lying maybe think our
problem is we have one on one site your
problem is young water three sides yeah
I talked to some of the Dutch books
there's Dutch bugs running around over
you're on top to that do business a date
they say we're looking forward to a lot
of good business it's a Google some hood
Netherlands floating houses and they
they've been engineering knows for quite
a while the real problem with isn't loss
of life but the complex caused by well
there's the migration issues yeah well
people are starting to try to figure out
what happens if if a whole lot of folks
at low levels on the us coasts have to
migrate some places even erickson just
Bangladesh courses worst yeah mobilize
lon
it may have been to Mumbai you know it's
like not very much family it's pretty
low too yeah yeah well I said yeah yeah
more can you say here's okay but it's a
while our prophet SAS Sacramento Delta
that's our College s yeah our probably
second is I don't know take the like all
committees until the troops is all good
you